so pittsburgh they sent a bit of a
statement to the rest of the national
football league beating the baltimore
ravens
it was a close game came all the way
down to a final heave into the end zone
there at the end what kind of a
statement do you think pitt proved
yesterday
i think they
they made a statement on offense and
defense you look at what ben
roethlisberger and to me he's been so
impressive i'm not just talking about
this past game but i'm just talking
about the entirety of the season i mean
think about a 38 year old guy that
didn't have training camp didn't have
otas didn't have all that extra time
coming off a major surgery on his elbow
and he's played great jack i mean i mean
aside from the first half yesterday i
mean in second half he came back and
made some some heck of a plays i mean
the guy has played phenomenal and you're
talking about a guy that hasn't even
taken a lot of reps in practice
the the big concern that i have with the
baltimore ravens is it seems like the
two best the two hurdles that they're
gonna have to get over in the afc one is
patrick mahomes in kansas city they
score too many points for the baltimore
ravens which becomes an issue because
they're really a team that likes to play
from ahead they don't want to play from
behind because that starts to take away
some of their running stuff the way they
like to use lamar in the running game
all those kind of things and then
pittsburgh is the other one that's
proven to be a tough match up for him
and it seems like lamar just has a
natural
struggle against some of those edge
defenders watt dupreeh
some of the guys to it that they throw
at him it seems like athletically
they're able to give lamar trouble as he
tries to just escape from a typical
four-man rush
yeah and that's why my tama came out
today and said you know what we have a
lot of respect for lamar but we don't
fear him because he knows how athletic
his defense is he knows dupree and watt
and those guys inside vince williams is
playing outstanding you see every week
mika fitzpatrick he's making a play joe
hayden had an interception i mean you
you see these these backup linebackers
come in and make plays and that's what
that's a credit to the head coach when
you have guys that are second string
third string coming in making plays and
fighting and clawing and doing
everything you can to win a football
game that's a direct credit to the head
coach mike tomlin he's been doing a
fantastic job
so rodney when you start looking around
the afc right now in the picture who are
your best maybe like a top five who
would be your top five teams in this afc
side of the picture
well number one would be kansas city
i just think with patrick mahomes he's
the x factor the pittsburgh still is
obviously with that defense the
baltimore ravens
lamar is still a young quarterback it's
gonna take some time he's gonna get
better the tennessee titans very
disappointed in that pass rush and the
buffalo bills are barely hanging in
there at six and two um teams are
starting to really take away the big
play with josh allen force him the dink
and dunk and see if he's patient enough
to do that and not not just live off the
big plays down the field
do you feel like at all that lamar
jackson has regressed as a passer we've
seen fewer designed runs this year for
him so you assume that he's going to
have to win from the pocket more often
they have weapons on the outside boykin
one hollywood brown another young guys
that are proven that they can you know
be great receivers in the national
football league but that's like 47 of
his passes something like that lamar
completed yesterday has he taken a step
backwards throwing the football
i wouldn't i wouldn't necessarily say
that he's taking a step backwards but i
just think from the offensive standpoint
what they're trying to make him do it's
like they're trying to force him to be
this passer to be this great passer as
opposed to running a football which they
had about 265 yards running the football
and i tell you this jack if they
continue to run the football yesterday
they win this ball game all they have to
do is run
the guy turned the ball over four times
i think it was two interceptions two
lost fumbles or something like that just
think if they're running the football
when he's throwing the ball then they
win that football game but yeah i think
they're they're putting so much pressure
on him
to to match up with patrick mahomes and
now ben roethlisberger and he's just not
built that way yes they have weapons
across the board but you got to run you
got to run a football you got to have
your defense create turnovers give you
field position and and that's how you're
going to win you're not going to win if
lamar has to go into the playoffs jack
throwing the ball 40 times they're not
going to win that way
and on the other side on the other side
offensively with the pittsburgh steelers
we talked about deontay johnson it's
essentially three sort of number one
number two feeling wide receivers that
the steelers play
and it's what's really been impressive
is they've recreated
you know go back to juju's rookie year
when they had antonio brown and juju on
the field at the same time were that was
when juju smith schuster was at his best
when when he had pressure taken off them
and claypool is now having the ability
showing the ability to do some of the
same things just relieve a little bit of
that juju pressure and what do we see
juju go out and have a big game
yeah and you think about pittsburgh they
have now what they have they have so
many talented guys first it was like
okay take away a b force them to go to
juju but now they have so many talented
guys you look at all the young talented
guys that they have it's hard to try to
take one guy out because they're very
unselfish as a team offensively they
don't care who who gets the numbers they
don't care who gets the touchdowns when
clay pool is and he's a rookie when he's
you know when he's doing his thing in
the end zone everybody's around him they
they're a very unselfish team all they
care about is winning but you look at
the weapons and i don't remember the
last time the pittsburgh steelers had
these many weapons especially young guys
making plays it's it's pretty remarkable
it looks like a team that's built to
make a deep deep playoff run all right
let's flip it over to another team who
maybe you know this may be phase one of
showing a team that can make some deep
playoff runs in the future the miami
dolphins all of a sudden they make a
change they they go no more fits magic
they bring in tula people are saying
you're crazy for doing it fitzpatrick
hasn't looked this good in a long time
he's on one of those rare heat streaks
that he has the ability to cook up they
make the change anyway but really the
star of this game was the miami defense
brian flores
absolutely and i think brian has done a
great job of making his team competitive
they have weapons on offense they got
good veterans on the defensive side they
they have really excellent cornerbacks
they got good safety play and they have
good people in the locker room and
that's what brian flores see he says you
know what we know that we're going to
struggle a little bit from time to time
with a tour but this is a very important
for him to come in get this valuable
experience and continue to help grow i
mean he he wants tua to be in that
locker room to help this team grow he's
the quarterback of the future and let's
face it ryan right ryan fitzpatrick is a
very streaky player he gets hot then
there's times when he gets cold and
they're trying to give two an
opportunity to be in there with the
first group with all those weapons
preston williams devonte parker all
those guys that they have they like i
said before they've done a wonderful job
on offensive side of providing him with
weapons and the the one thing that i'm
looking at which i looked at yesterday
yesterday when i think it was michael
brocker's jumped on his back
and now that had to feel good for him
for a guy that is coming off a major
injury to get hit and then to get up and
say you know what
i'm okay that builds confidence in a
young man so i expect him each week as
he walks off the field he's healthy to
continue to gain that confidence and
just feel good about himself
that's exactly what was like the second
play of the game or something it just
like kind of got right on top and sort
of brought him into the ground yeah
that's exactly what it was i thought it
was the perfect game to ease two in
too you know it's so much easier when
you really learn what it's like to sort
of go from the jv to the varsity heck
yeah the perfect game because the
defense was the dominator the defense
was the one that was building this miami
lead they just continued to take they
take it away from about five times every
single series they were taking the ball
away from golf but you and so they had a
great field position or they had a lead
yeah go ahead
you you didn't know that going into the
game you didn't know that the defense
was going to play like that so you're
telling me with aaron aaron donald
michael brockers and all those things
all those defenders that they have that
can get to the quarterback you're
telling me you thought this was the
perfect game and i'm sitting here i was
like
oh my goodness i
remember when the rams played against
washington
the football team washington and aaron
donald jumped on alex smith back
and alex smith kind of carried him and
it was a sack well i was thinking the
same thing i'm like okay
so how do you know that that's what
that's my question to you how did you
know that this was the perfect game
the the reason i say it is not so much
like the lead up into the game i mean
going into the game i'm thinking do you
really want to start him against aaron
donald that defensive front i'm thinking
that the rams are going to be coming
into this game ticked and go off i'm
just saying the process of how this
played out
it's rare that you're going to have a
flores defense but remember this is the
same defense flores studied under who
bill belichick remember what bill
belichick did to sean mcvay and the rams
in the super bowl just a couple of years
ago
this game gave me flashes back to that
they were putting seven or eight men at
the line of scrimmage and just making
golf confused is he gonna blitz is he
gonna blitz is he gonna drop is he gonna
drop he had no clue and half the time he
was just throwing it to one of them the
linebacker would be up around the line
of scrimmage dropped back and golf was
just throwing him the football and they
kept hitting him right when he was in
the middle of his throwing motion too
and that was that is what continuously
was creating turnover opportunities
whether it was just a throw that sort of
flew up into the air and became an easy
pick or a fumble or whatever the case
may be it was all pressure driven but
when i'm saying it was the perfect game
for two to come into it's so much easier
to play quarterback when you just have
to manage a lead and not go build a lead
against jared goff because the reality
is the star of this game was flores and
what he did to mcveigh what he did
confusing golf and ultimately tua got to
go out there and throw about 10 or 12
passes and win an easy blowout
yeah but think about it i mean brian
flores came up with a heck of a game
plan but that game plan won't work every
week against every individual individual
team so you're going to need to uh
you're not going to always play with the
league you're going to you're going to
be down two touchdowns you might be down
10 points and my big question is is two
are good enough
is he good enough to bring this team
back and there's a lot of questions it's
going to take time and brian flores know
that this is the year that they want to
be patient with tour give them an
opportunity to get those valuable reps
because when you get in there and you
start seeing live action compared to
what was at the sc sec compared to the
nfl and now you see man he was an
all-american he was an all-american wow
he was all-conference like that's what
you get when you playing a national
football league and i'm
the thing that really i liked about tua
he was just so humble and he was so
grateful and he was like hey thank god
we got a good defense but that's the
type of guy they have leading at
quarterback and i think they're going to
do big things in the future
i do too and i don't think he could have
a better mentor than fitz and i know
fitz said that right he didn't want to
necessarily give up the job at the time
that he did but i have no question about
his ability to shift gears a little bit
and then go into coach mode and bring
two up to it for everything you'll be
seeing from tua he seems like a pretty
easy guy to hang out with and coach up
and bring to speed
that seems like we're just a match mate
in heaven between those two all right
let's get to somebody else
cam newton so cam newton has been one of
the great roller coaster rides of this
entire nfl season at first it looked
like it was going to be perfect bringing
them in there and then all of a sudden
new england goes into kansas city
without cam newton and had them all over
the ropes it looked like they were going
to upset the chiefs without cam newton
that game falls apart in ever since the
new england season has really fallen
apart when you watched this game
yesterday buffalo new england what was
your biggest takeaway
well i mean kind of what coach belichick
said after the game he said hey i trust
cam he's going to be our quarterback
moving forward and i still believe that
kim gives the patriots the best chance
to win
you know and it's just it's tough man
you know when when you're out there
fighting your clawing and you don't have
many weapons they're not creating any
separation you're not getting any
production from the tight end position i
thought the offensive line was solid i
thought they stepped up and they
competed but cam knows and that's one of
bill belichick's one of his biggest
things you have to be able to protect
the football if you can't protect the
football you cannot play how many times
have we watched the patriots and we've
seen a running back and he's having a
heck of a game he fumbles one time and
he's gone
i mean i've been around where they
they've cut guys you know what i'm
saying from fumbling and turning the
ball over so right now coach belichick
is being extremely patient with cam but
cam knows better and this cam is planned
for his football life because people say
oh coach belichick can't get cam right
okay we don't want no part of cam
so he knows what he has to do and he has
to definitely play better and and
protect the football jack
it looks like a jv team to me rodney
when you go back and you watch this game
like if if you took cam newton off the
field i just don't know that you would
recognize
anybody that they're putting out there i
mean anybody there doesn't seem like
their size doesn't seem like their speed
it just seems like any wide receiver
they could pick up off the free agent
wire and bring in that's sort of the
group that they've put together and now
they're they're trying to go all in on
like a college style of offense where
they want to ground and pound and hammer
the football and then run some option
run some reverses run just a short quick
easy passing game very rarely if ever do
you see them pushing the ball down the
field but when they do cam has had some
success i mean came looked okay throwing
the football in this game to me at least
but still the real haunting one coming
off of halloween here the real haunting
one is nikhil harry i i just feel like
every week coach belichick watching dk
metcalf and knowing that he could have
had him you know 32 picks something like
that earlier has to just be one of the
great haunting draft picks of
belichick's lifetime
uh absolutely man and i just i sit there
and i watch dk metcalf and i said wow we
as a patriot organization we had an
opportunity to get this guy and we
didn't get him
and it just hurts because you know you
bring in you draft a guy in the first
round you think he's gonna come in and
be a difference maker and he's just a
guy and that's what the patriots have
all the receivers are just guys then you
have edelman who wants to be out there
he doesn't care if he's out there on one
leg his knee is messed up and he might
be done for the season now you got cam
trying to you know deal with all these
average football players and this i just
think you know i love coach belichick i
have a lot of respect for him but he's
done a poor job of assimilating um
talent and this is the reason why brady
wanted out because brady knew i can't
play with this garbage and look at what
he's playing with now he's playing with
former r pros and pro bowlers and he's
got a good offensive line run game great
defense like
brady looks like a genius for leaving
the patriots at this point
he does he does rodney does it change
the way that you view cam though i mean
we we just laid out everybody he's
playing with i mean if you don't believe
it's like just go watch a minute of the
game even go pull up the the stats and
just look at the names you recognize
almost nobody so does it change the way
that you view cam newton because this is
going to be
i mean for his football life this is one
of the biggest offseasons he's going to
come to where he basically has no
contract he's making almost nothing this
year is there still going to be interest
is there still going to be a market out
there for him is this a cam issue or is
this a new england issue
i think it's a it's both i mean as an
individual player you know when you mess
up you don't point your finger and say
hey it's your fault it's your fault now
you look in the mirror as a man and you
say you know what i have to do better
and that's one thing i respect with him
and that was one of the things that i
was looking for
you know this season when he hit some
adversity how would he how will he
handle adversity and i think he's been
great he stood in front of the camera in
front of the microphones and he said you
know what i have to play better i have
to do better and he's taking blame and
accountability and i think his teammates
like him but they like that and respect
that but at the end of the day you have
to play better
you have to play better we can't keep
talking about the same mistakes over and
over and over again and that's what cam
doing cam is doing his his heart is
right his intentions are right but
fumbling
interceptions throwing the ball into the
ground i mean
when you watch tape i want you to watch
one thing how many times have you seen
cam drop back and like look like he's
throwing the ball as hard as he possibly
can and the ball goes directly into the
ground
it seems like it happens every single
game like
i've never seen a quarterback throw so
many balls into the dirt and i'm trying
to figure out like what's wrong with cam
like what's going on what happened from
seattle remember when he played against
seattle and he threw out like three or
four hundred yards
to now what happened
edelman being off the field probably is
one of the factors i mean edelman really
hasn't been healthy all year and he took
a big shot in that seattle game i mean
if
we were at that game watching it live so
you could tell i mean he would he would
literally get up and look like he took a
big shot kind of right in the head early
on in the game
and he would run and he would go do
crazy stuff after the catch but then he
would get tackled and he could almost
barely get up and walk back to the
huddle he's already was dealing with the
knee so i think you know julian edelman
not being out there he was one of very
few if not the only that i think cam
newton had confidence in terms of where
he was going to be give him chances
one-on-one and now that he's gone
it's a big hit to the passing game and
that nikhil harry hasn't developed into
a true number one is another big hit to
the passing game but everything we're
talking about despite all of this
despite the no names despite it looking
like a jv team this team was down three
driving to go win the game with 37
seconds left if cam newton doesn't
fumble the ball they very well might win
this game so so back to the point about
cam having his shoulder a little blame
he does have to because they still had a
chance to win this thing down the
stretch
but coach belichick and everybody on
that team has to show to blame because
we're not used to seeing the patriots
fall apart in critical moments of the
game that's what makes them the patriots
that's what makes them champions that's
what separates them from everyone else
because they don't make those mistakes
in critical moments you don't see the
penalties the offsides the past
interferences you don't see those mental
mistakes by the patriots and you sit
back and you watch what you're saying
now you look and you know that they're
playing with a lot of young players but
they still have a lot of their core guys
and i just look and i just shake my head
man and at the end of the day i've
talked about it yesterday and i'm
talking about it today i'm done talking
about the patriots we spent enough time
on the patriots
yeah i'm with you i'm with you and if
cam's gonna keep running the ball in
between the tackles he needs to get two
hands on that sucker because not only do
you not have it on the outside hand and
on the inside hand and one hand there
could be a lot of fumbles on that all
right let's keep it within some great
runners
dalvin cook all of a sudden dalvin cook
single-handedly kept the lights on for
minnesota in a wild upset win now you
may be looking at something trendy here
for the packers back to pack losses
after you had almost an mvp looking
start out of aaron rodgers
how did minnesota how did one singular
running back in dalvin cook dismantle
the entire green bay defense well he's a
top five running back and when he comes
back this is a totally different offense
and when they commit to running a
football you see those offensive linemen
they get charged up they get energized
and it just takes everything to the next
level and then you start thinking about
play-action pass and kirk cousins where
everything doesn't have to be on kirk
cousins he can kind of just do his thing
turn around hand the ball off throw a
little flare pass to um you know to cook
and let him do his thing but cook is the
difference maker on this team i like
they got two good young you know two
wide good wide receivers solid tight end
but they're a completely different team
when they commit to running the football
regardless of how much they're paying
kirk cousins you know thinking that he's
going to be the guy you have to run the
football take that pressure off kurt
i mean kurt thought 14 passes yesterday
think about that exactly making all that
money all that guaranteed money 14
passes cook 30 rushes it it reminded me
a little bit of the watching the saints
play just watching this offense where it
was like every play
what is option number one what's the
best thing that could happen on this
play get dalvin cook the ball in space
when you watch the saints play what's
the best that can happen
every single snap
get the ball to alvin kamara in space
and hope for the best it had a little
bit of that same feel and honestly cook
and camaro are probably pretty similar
players when you really step back and
think about it
yeah and you know what i look at aaron
jones too and no one's really talking
about aaron jones aaron jones he's the
best player on the green bay packers
he's missed a couple games and all of a
sudden you see
this offense isn't the same and and and
jack i don't know man
i don't know i don't know if this is a
contract move i don't know if he's
legitimately injured i don't know if
it's a combination of both but a lot of
times people don't know what you're
worth until you're not there and him not
being there he's making money just think
about how much money he's making and how
valuable he looks they haven't looked
the same since he's been gone aaron
jones is the best player on that offense
and and you can see why
it's a really good point and it's it's
almost like they drafted the insurance
policy or they drafted the future and aj
dillon and we're going to go get this
power running back and this is going to
be the next phase and we're not we're
going to do everything the data
analytics people tell us we're not gonna
pay the running back a big contract
we're already playing paying the
quarterback a couple billion so we can't
afford it anyway but to make the
transition from you know a a backup
quarterback in the first round of the
draft with the team that clearly is
built to win right now to go get a
backup quarterback in jordan love was a
shot at disrespect and then with the
second pick to go get a running back
that's not even somebody who can go win
in the passing game like we're talking
about like a dalvin cook a camara
and aaron jones a true power running
back i mean that is what dylan is
i i just i what's wrong with that
around the thinking
i just can't wrap my head around the
thinking when you have somebody like
aaron rodgers who can run around and get
the ball to jones in space and you know
have so much magic with this offense the
way it's currently built and you go try
to build a totally new future with a
team that's already
able to win it makes no the logic of it
makes no sense to me
well to me i disagree with you because
it is very logical because aaron jones
is your guy they're going to pay aaron
jones trust me all right because
just like you talked about they went out
and got jordan love and drafted him so
aaron rodgers might get another year i
think they're going to pay guns
oh yeah
absolutely you see you see what happened
the last two weeks aaron jones is that
dude man he can play he's a baller
i mean you see aaron and and trust me
aaron rodgers knows i mean he's
complaining about some past interference
call but
the versatility of aaron jones and when
he's out there lined up as a wide
receiver if you put number 82 on him
guess what you would think that he's a
slot receiver that's how good he is he's
good in pass protection he's smart he's
tough he can run between the tackles and
back to your boy aj dillon they're not
looking for aj dillon to come in and
replace aaron jones two totally
different skill types what they're
thinking about is when we're second and
one or third down and two and we need
those yards and we gotta have it or
we're in a two minute or a four minute
offense where we have to run the ball
out we're gonna get this power back so
we don't have to worry about our 195 200
pound running back getting pounded
that's the reason why they went out and
got aj um dylan
i can respect that but but rogers could
use another wide receiver or maybe
another tight end another something
you know what i'm saying like i respect
what they're doing there but that you're
putting a lot especially if you're
you're saying that they're gonna pay
jones and you're putting a second round
draft pick into his back up when you
clearly need more bodies a wide receiver
that's where i go
what's the big picture strategy here i
mean what what's what's the thought
process and i really think it is a
disjointed front office given that
rogers thinks and sees it one way and
has such a big voice and now lefleur
sees and feels it a different way and
there's a little bit of this going on
well players are always going to think a
little differently than what management
or the head coach may think but aaron
aaron rodgers his responsibility is to
that team and his job is about taking
care of business on that football field
you can't worry about who they draft and
who they go get and the fact that he he
felt like he was either disrespected or
they did something behind his back at
the end of the day you can't control
what goes on upstairs all you can
control is what you put out on that
football field and if you put out
winning football and you're making nice
passes and you're not turning the ball
over whether you're in green bay aaron
rodgers or whether you're somewhere else
somebody's gonna pay you and somebody's
going to love and appreciate you because
you are a great quarterback period
100 100 all right this is kind of a fun
transition because
from what i've been told joe burrow
actually had a little bit of influence
over keeping aj green now aj green has
turned into not the best wide receiver
on the bengals by far it has been t
higgins it has been tyler boyd the young
guys that have really taken over and it
makes you think some it's like why
didn't the bengals just trade dalton
trade green trade dunlap maybe trade
atkins at the end of last year and just
load up on starting offensive lineman if
you knew you're gonna go take joe burrow
number one overall
oh why don't you just if you're the
patriots and i said i wouldn't talk
about them but if you're the patriots
why wouldn't you go get a four foot
fifth round and ask for aj green and we
talked about this i think on our first
show it's like you know i said aj green
is a guy that i definitely would have
traded i don't know what his salary is
but i'm sure he's making anywhere from
nine to fourteen million a year
so franchise tax i don't know i'm gonna
he's getting the top five average yeah
right he's he's making a lot of monies
and you know he's just no longer a top
receiver but i would have traded them
but it's always good to have good
veteran players in that locker room that
can you know they can speak and and aj
green can say you know what i remember
when when we were horrible when we we
couldn't win a football game so
we'll see but i was i'm thoroughly
impressed with umbro he is he is that
guy man
how you like him yeah you got your guy
you mentioned green i mean green's
making he's making over 18 million
dollars and he's visibly the third wide
receiver but this is years in a row now
that you've seen tyler boyd coming up
and showing signs of the potential of
being a number one you go take t higgins
the top of round two in the first round
draft pick in the second round draft
pick have instantaneously clicked and
from everything i've heard it sounded
like burrow and higgins were able to
spend a lot of time this off-season in a
quarantine training location developing
a lot of chemistry that's instantly
clicked on the field when they've been
together but i live in cincinnati
cincinnati right now hanging out here
doing the show from cincinnati a week
ago
all around town everybody is calling for
the head of zach taylor they have to
move in a different direction they have
to get a new coach like what are you
talking about
they might not have a bunch of wins on
the season but this team is playing with
everybody they have been in every game
against playoff looking like teams and
they've been hanging to the wires
they're gonna take a minute to learn how
to win yeah but they already showed that
they can win and they did so yesterday
against a really good tennessee titans
team
man joe burrow is he's a rookie but he's
not a rookie and i tell you those guys
in the locker room they respect him they
uh they they respect the way he stands
up for him they ex they respect
the way he sits in the pocket he gets
crushed he's not yelling and screaming
as teammates anything like that they
respect him period and i have a lot of
respect for the young men
anybody not named mahomes young
quarterbacks not name the homes there is
not
anyone not a single one i would take
right now over joe burrow i just he has
he has that special
factor about him where it's like the
game could be going great the game could
be going awful they could have lost all
these tight fourth quarter finishes
where he really had won the game there's
like at least three or four games this
year where he deserved to win based on
the way he played not only throughout
the course of the game but fourth
quarter closing it finishing it and then
the defense just gives up something wild
back the other way but he just continues
to come to work he's a workman like he's
got that steady demeanor that you're
talking about where they just trust that
he'll be able to finish the game late
but what i really liked about this
titans game is that he didn't leave it
up to the defense he had that drive at
the end that put it away that put it at
double digits plus that really won him
this football game he just looks to me
like he's going to be 10 to 15 years the
future of the cincinnati bengals and i
really have no doubt in my mind about
that
dude it's amazing because you sit here
and you look at the kid and you can tell
you know how talented he is and all the
you know the intangibles that he brings
and to me i sit back and i was able to
play with brady for six years and he's a
lot more athletic than brady and those
guys like he could be a really good
quarterback for a long time and i expect
him here in the next couple years to be
one of the top quarterbacks
if not the top quarterback in that
division
i'm with you and you think about
eventually at some point in time big ben
as good as he's looking right now will
hang it up and so then he steps right in
there with lamar jackson as one of the
best
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports